jax teller's shakespearean tragedy ends
in predictably catastrophic style on
sons of anarchy this is jax's rocky road
from acting as vice president of sam
crowe to enacting revenge upon his
stepfather clay and his own mother gemma
for his father's murder jax's father
john teller was an idealist vietnam vet
and founding member of the sons he hopes
that the charming california biker club
would have a positive influence on the
world after losing his youngest son
jax's little brother thomas to a heart
defect he fell into a deep depression
and began putting the history of the
club down in his memoir while john was
constantly running off with his mistress
gemma was left to deal with thomas's
illness and subsequent passing alone she
agreed to help clay put an end to jon in
a stage to road accident clay quickly
became club president and began
entangling the club deeper with other
organized criminal elements and that's
just a backstory
jax is in turmoil when the show opens
the club's warehouse has mysteriously
burned down on the same day his pregnant
ex-wife wendy overdoses on heroin and is
rushed to the hospital where jax
discovers his high school sweetheart
tara will be one of his child surgeons i
want to help your son
his name is abel
abel teller is delivered via c-section
and thanks to tara's surgical
intervention beats the two-to-one odds
against his survival tara and jax
reunited for the first time since high
school begin to fall into a relationship
in spite of themselves while looking for
baby clothing for abel jax finds his
father's writings in a storage crate and
becomes inspired by the old man's vision
for sam crow which the club is decidedly
not living up to and the clay the suns
ultimately find themselves divided when
donna the wife of jax's best friend and
trusted lieutenant opie is accidentally
killed by tigg clay sergeant at arms the
bullet was intended for opie whom clay
falsely believed as informing on the sun
thanks to information planted by june
style an atf agent trying to take down
the suns
sam crowe soon finds themselves in a
turf war with a league of american
nationalists a militant white
supremacist group as clay and jack's vie
are control of the club gemma is
kidnapped beaten and sexually assaulted
by the league united by a desire for
vengeance clay and jack's combined
forces to remove the nazis from charming
for good how do you want to handle it
we kill them all
just as the coast seems clear jax learns
that abel has been kidnapped by the head
of the true irish republican army who
believes that gemma is involved with the
death of his son jackson the sons head
to belfast to recover the boy where jax
meets his father's mistress maureen who
gives him more of his father's letters
to add to his collection after jax
returns home aidan's style offers him
legal immunity for gemma and lighter
sentences for the sons if he turns on
them upon learning that terror is
pregnant jax takes the deal stalin forms
a club of their negotiations but instead
of turning on jax opie takes our style
avenging his wife's death jack soon
learns our stars has set them up and the
club ends up in prison after a 14-month
prison sentence jax and the gang are
released jack's plans on exiting the
club and making a better life for
himself terror and his children but gets
drawn even deeper into club business
gemma discovers maureen's letters from
john among jax's things detailing his
suspicion that gemma and clay were
conspiring to kill him clay kills
multiple people to suppress the truth
including opie's father clay and gemma
begin to come apart at the seams their
relationship exploding after a
particularly ugly fight gemma has the
letters altered to remove proof of her
involvement in jon's death then informs
jax that clay arranged his father's
murder clay gets voted out of the club
presidency with jack assuming control of
the suns the club soon runs afoul of a
gang seeking revenge after tig killed
the daughter of their leader daemon pope
tara and jax finally marry and the sons
find themselves imprisoned once again to
pay off their debt to pope they're
forced to trade the life of one of their
imprisoned members opie volunteers and
is brutally beaten to death in one of
the series most gruesome scenes jax
later kills pope and pins a hit on clay
after a gun connected to the sons is
used in a school shooting jax decides to
get out of their ira related gun trade
but clay imprisoned for the murder of
pope relies on the ira and a few of his
some crow buddies to break him out of
prison the resulting mess concludes with
jax finally shooting clay to death and
pinning it on the ira
fair enough
tara is given the chance to turn state's
evidence against the suns and gemma
believes she's already turned on them
though jackson terra have reconciled
gemma takes it upon herself to protect
her son she stabs terra to death and
absconds before she's discovered leaving
jax alone to find his wife and mourn
with nothing left to lose and the love
of his life now gone jax goes on a
roaring rampage of revenge eventually
catching up with gemma at her father's
house he kills his mother in her garden
entering a dark place from which he
can't return jack says goodbye to his
sons and entrusts them to wendy he also
gives wendy all of his possessions and
instructs her to take the boys and leave
charming ensuring they won't grow up in
the club i need my sons
to grow up
hating the thought of me
he leaves his club ringer opie's grave
and kisses tara's headstone before
visiting the place where his father died
announcing his forgiveness leading the
police on a chase down the same highway
where his father died jax drives his
motorcycle head on into a semi-truck
ending his life in the same place and in
the same way his father died years ago
just like the ending of hamlet it's a
bloodbath unlike the ending of hamlet
however two small boys get a chance at a
peaceful life check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite tv
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]